hey everybody it's Mike frieder here
with on-call compliance Solutions and
I'm back with another compliance tip of
the week this week we're talking about
cmmc control cm.l2-3.4.8
apply deny by exception blacklisting
policy to prevent the use of
unauthorized software or deny all permit
by exception white listing policy to
allow the execution of authorized
software
[Music]
okay
so hey if you're a defense contractor
who's feeling overwhelmed tired and
alone trying to understand all this cmmc
dfars and nist SP 800 171 compliant
stuff on top of an already colossal
workload well I've got great news for
you you found your home here at on-call
compliance Solutions where we can help
you transform into your company's
on-call compliance Hero Let's jump into
it cmmc control
cm.l2-3.4.8 apply deny by exception
blacklisting policy to prevent the use
of unauthorized software or deny all
permit by exception wait listing policy
to allow the execution of authorized
software okay so here we really uh are
getting into some of the hard
requirements where they don't give you
so much leeway and how the system is
configured right so they're sort of
setting some hard requirements on this
one you must either Blacklist or
whitelist software many ways to do this
many solutions on there uh you know out
there from stuff that's built into
windows and Microsoft server to you know
also aftermarket Solutions but the
bottom line is you must demonstrate that
you have clear control over the software
that is installed on your system so the
users can't just do whatever they want
right obviously it's a pretty big
security issue if users are able to just
randomly install whatever software they
want meaning that anybody that might get
remote control over their computer could
also do the same thing so not a good
thing and we just need tighter control
over the software and what those
computers are able to do so let's dive
into details to see what the assessors
are looking for on this one a couple
things you're looking for uh three
things actually determine if a policy
specifying whether whitelisting or
blacklisting is to be implemented is
specified now it's kind of interesting
because the first step in this is hey is
there a policy at all basically
whitelisting blacklisting doesn't matter
but do you have a policy one of the most
common answers I think you'll probably
see is going to be something to the
extent of hey Group Policy defines that
only white listed software is allowed to
be installed and only by authorized it
administrators in accordance with an
authorized request through the
organization's I.T ticketing system here
again the example really is is that the
group policy is going to be the what is
controlling the software and of course
normally you would probably set Group
Policy as a best practice to say hey all
the administrators can install software
assessment Point number two determine if
the software allowed to execute under
whitelisting or denied under
blacklisting is specified the software
Allowed by whitelist uh IE permit is
specified in the organization's Baseline
configuration and network inventory
documentation so again we're going to
specify exactly where it is how it
operates and of course where it's
documented assessment Point number three
determinative white listing to allow the
execution of authorized software or
blacklisting to prevent the use of
unauthorized software is implemented as
specified again Group Policy restricting
execution of authorized is implemented
users may only execute whitelisting
permitted software for which their user
account has access which is granted
permitting by privilege I.T
administrators now if you want an
example of blacklisting another example
of that could potentially be something
like hey we have antivirus in place
along with firewall policies that will
Blacklist any program that does this
function so maybe communicates on the
same supports as maybe
torrent programs something like that so
again there's lots and lots of ways to
answer this question hopefully those
examples help out quite a bit and of
course at on call we help defense
contractors just like you who've had all
of this dfars nist itar and cmmc
compliance stuff dropped into their laps
like a seagull on a sunny day we teach
you how to level up and be a proper
on-call compliance hero for your company
eliminating gaps gray areas and getting
this all solved while showing you how to
leverage compliance is your secret
weapon to land more Defense work with
higher profit margins now that's what
becoming an on-call compliance hero can
do for you if you're looking for more
help getting compliant our compliance
experts are always on call for you if
you visit cmmc compliance secrets.com or
you can check out the description below
for links to get help right now if you
love the content we're putting out there
for you help us out with a big thumbs up
on that like button or even better smash
that subscribe button to get the latest
compliance content as soon as our
compliance nerds roll it out until the
next compliance tip my friends stay safe
and secure out there hit us in the
comments below to let us know what you'd
like to know more about well when it
comes to information security and
compliance I'll see you on the next one
[Music]